you've had a chance to look over the
syllabus for this course what value do
you think it might have for learners in
the outside world and would you
recommend that they take a look at these
readings and try to apply them to their
own lives definitely I mean if we want
to have any constructive impact on the
world
any interchange with the world that will
improve it we'll deal with the
innumerable problems that exist it has
to be based on understanding of social
political economic reality otherwise you
can't act in any serious way just as you
couldn't go into a chemistry lab and
conduct an experiment unless you knew
something about chemistry otherwise you
could mix chemicals and make funny
smells and so on but if you want to do
something serious you have to understand
first and the syllabus of the course and
the conduct of the course is aimed and I
think succeeds in providing the kind of
fundamental understanding and challenge
open questions that people have to think
about if they want to be able to
participate in a meaningful way and the
general Society